[Music]
a few decades ago we actually saw
explosions in the sky somewhere out in
space that we really didn't understand
at all
they gave intense bursts of something
called gamma rays and gamma rays are the
highest energy kind of light that is
possible now you've probably heard of
you know ultraviolet rays from the Sun
they give you sunburn and then there are
things like x-rays gamma rays are even
more more energetic and more dangerous
to us than that but gamma rays are only
created in the universe by things that
are naturally in the billions of degrees
and we saw these little gamma-ray pops
going off in space and at first we
wondered well are they are they nearby
you know could they be in our own galaxy
or are they very far away we really
didn't know and a few decades ago we
actually realized that these gamma-ray
bursts were coming from very very
distant galaxies galaxies that in most
cases were billions of light years away
and a light near is about six trillion
miles the distance that light travels in
one year so billions of light-years away
and so something was creating a lot of
gamma rays because they were bright
enough to measure from that distance and
incredibly some of these explosions were
so intense there was one I believe it
was in 2007 but NASA observed there was
a little flash of visible light that
came with the gamma rays and it was
actually visible with the naked eye for
a couple of minutes if you were actually
in the southern hemisphere on that night
you would have seen a little star turn
on and off for a couple of minutes that
would have been gone and that explosion
happened about seven billion light-years
away something blew up seven billion
years ago on almost the other side of
the observable universe and it was
bright enough to see with the unaided
eye we had discovered something
unbelievable what could possibly be that
bright what could possibly be that
violent that little explosion for a few
minutes out shown the rest of the
observable universe just one thing so we
really didn't know what could possibly
create that much energy and the the
theoretical physicist got to work and
they started just kind of guessing I
mean I mean what what could explode that
could make that much energy and it turns
out that if you have these these things
called neutron
stars neutron stars with the leftover
compressed cores of dead stars
they are amazing monsters they're about
10 miles across and they have a density
that if you had about a teaspoon full of
the material that that would be about as
much as the mass as Mount Everest
crushed into a teaspoonful they're
amazing things and we observe hundreds
of thousands of these things in space
and so people sort of theorized that if
two of these things spiral together and
collided you would actually be able to
get that much energy out it seemed
unlikely but you know maybe that does
happen sometime in the universe the two
of these things collide now Einstein
came up with this wonderful idea that
space and time is almost kind of like a
fabric that connects everything in the
universe and what gravity is is gravity
is kind of a pulling and stretching on
that fabric and if you have two really
massive things moving around each other
very fast before they collide say to two
neutron stars spiraling spiraling in
they should actually make ripples in
this fabric so as they spiral closer and
closer together they actually make
ripples that actually go out through
space at the speed of light and these
are called gravitational waves and they
are very very hard to find I mean lucky
for us mass is moving around only create
tiny little distortions in space and
time the fabric of space and time itself
so what happened is if we actually
started building instruments that were
sensitive enough sensitive enough to
detect this tiny little wobble in space
and time itself
and to give you an idea about how hard
this is to detect we used an instrument
called LIGO the laser interferometric
gravitational wave observatory and LIGO
has two lasers and the lasers are about
two miles long and they actually at a
right angle so two mile long lasers
added sort of a corner shape and the
idea was that if one of these ripples in
space and time comes through one of the
sides of the laser in this corner
construction would actually be warped a
little more than the other and you'd
actually see that space and time itself
were changing a little more in one
direction as this ripple came through
the ripple is so small that over a two
mile laser the distance space and time
changes is by about a thousandth of the
diameter of a proton
we have an instrument that can measure
that and amazingly we started seeing
these ripples coming from many different
places in the sky as these neutron stars
collided and spiraled together and the
thing that was so wonderful this only
happened last year is that one of these
gamma ray bursts one of these ultra
violent explosions that we had no idea
really what they could be went off and
at the same time at the speed of light
with those gamma rays came that ripple
that signal that exactly matched two
neutron stars spiraling together we had
guessed that the only thing that could
actually make that much energy were
these two dead stars colliding and now
we had evidence and the evidence was a
ripple in space and time a thousand
times smaller than a proton
[Music]
you